yes it's quite possibly the worst ending
in television history with a guy who
decided to warg into Ravens during the
biggest battle of all time becoming King
in this video we'll be looking at the
season finale of Game of Thrones and see
where they [ __ ] up along the way so
grab a hold of any sense of logic
because here we go
do you like ten minutes of walking
through ash and seeing the aftermath of
a battle that in no way advances the
story well you're in luck in fact 10% of
this entire episode is no dialogue
walking but at least this moment shows
what it's supposed to the absolute
devastation Daenerys is caused by
killing hundreds of thousands of unarmed
civilians from burn Kidd corpses to the
walking dead as if it's something out of
her Oshima Tyrion tells Jon that'll find
him later but Jon knows what's up if
tiering goes to Danny he's dead meat so
he offers him some men but Tyrion
decides to accept his fate and go at it
alone he's a man of integrity and he's
willing to die and stand up for the
choices he's made we also get this shot
at the red keep
utterly destroyed and it makes me wonder
what the point of this entire series is
it's Game of Thrones but us will see
later on there will be no throne at all
the throne is but a metaphor for power
and that power is now in a new throne a
wheelchair grey worm who I once
respected is a total dick even though he
doesn't have one
he kills these Lannister men even though
they've surrendered but grey worm isn't
totally at fault here he's just
following the orders of Queen Daenerys
but when John calls him out he's
confronted with grey worms men something
tells me this convo with Dany won't go
over well Tyrion walks through the halls
of the red keep where Cersei once
planned her attacks not only on Daenerys
but Tyrion himself it's in the catacombs
he uncovers the bodies of Jaime and
Cersei and breaks down crying now I
understand him crying over Jaime who he
bonded with over eight seasons but
Cersei give me a break
this is a woman who wanted him dead mad
props to Peter Dinklage having to put up
with a [ __ ] hand he was given by DND he
went with it and he gave it his all can
we also discuss that Jaime and Cersei
died by rubble rubble two of the most
integral characters in the entire series
died by falling bricks it's just plain
lazy and indicative
the rush nature of this season Aria
watches John Traverse the Dothraki and
the sullied up the ruined steppes of
King's Landing and somehow brain worm
has transported here as well and I will
say this shot of Danny and Rogan is
[ __ ] epic Danny gives an impassioned
speech the unsullied in Dothraki telling
them that their sacrifices weren't in
vain they've won and now they will rule
ready to shape the world anew she names
grey worm as her master of war the
commander of all her forces this is a
man who just a few episodes ago was
ready to travel off with Bosson day to
live in peace and now that she's dead is
total cool with being a master of war my
favorite line here is from Danny who
says they freed King's Landing from a
tyrant
have you seen King's Landing it's
literally me after a Chipotle who freed
all the people who are dead you frickin
idiot but Danny doesn't end there she
won't rest until all the world is
liberated she talks about Winterfell and
Dorne falling under her control which
undoubtedly means more bloodshed and for
Jon who knows what that will mean for
Sansa who has already expressed her
concerns with the Queen Daenerys and
holy [ __ ] the balls of Tyrion he lets
Dany know that even though he freed his
brother Danny slaughtered an entire city
he throws his middle ass the hand of the
Queen badge as a final Fu before he's
taken into custody
Jon just watches on like Hagar always
still good but we'll get to that in a
bit and look who just magically shows up
using her ninja powers Arya she came to
kill Cersei but the Queen got there
first
no Arya bricks got to her first the
weird thing here is that Jon tells her
that Dany is her queen now he's still
not convinced and this to me is WTF
central he's the rightful heir to the
throne watching a person who just killed
close to a million people yes King's
Landing is home to a million people and
you gotta love Tyrion the first thing he
says when Jon comes in is if he's
brought any wine he tells John that he
watched his close friend burns wait
since when was Varys Tyrians closest
friend give me a break
yes he helped you escape from King's
Landing in season four but he wasn't
doing that out of friendship he was
doing that because it was a good
political move for him the fact Tyrion
can't see that is just silly now here's
one of the most
Nicholas conversations in Game of
Thrones history we have Jon Snow one of
the most noble men not unlike Eddard in
the entire show
try to defend Annie's actions killing
hundreds of thousands of innocents it's
like trying to watch Jesus stiffen
genocide it doesn't make any sense
and Tyrion catches him in this lie when
he asks would you have done it would you
have killed those people
and he won't answer he'd rather be wrong
and not betray then be right and lose
his integrity to Danny
Tyrion once believed in Danny with all
his heart and he tells John that love is
more powerful than reason John is not
thinking with his head just like Jamie
put love before reason he leaves John
with a warning who does he think Danny
will see is the biggest threat to the
Iron Throne
and of course it's John the rightful
heir with a final plea he tells him if
he honestly believes Sansa will bend the
knee he needs to make a choice not just
for himself but for his family and yes
this looks cool but did a [ __ ] ton of
rubble just fall on Drogo on while he
was sleeping don't worry guys he's
bigger than Jaime and Cersei it
shouldn't harm him Dany approaches the
ruins of the Iron Throne because who
wouldn't want to be the queen of this
dilapidated throne room and Jon arrives
with absolutely no one else in the room
is no one protecting the Queen grey worm
this is your first day in the job [ __ ]
what's going on Danny tries to justify
her death of hundreds of children by
saying that they were simply Circe's
shields this is a woman who locked up
her dragons because they killed one
innocent child seasons ago she tells
John that they can build a new world
from scratch together but if there's one
thing we know about Jon Snow it's that
he knows nothing you know nothing Jon
Snow he stabs Dany and no one else is
around to see it except for the giant
friggin dragon is no one else in this
castle what the hell is going on I will
say if there was anyone to kill Danny at
this point it is Jon so at least the
writers didn't screw that out
hey the iron throne people have been
fighting over for eight seasons doesn't
mean [ __ ] let's burn the crap out of it
just like the night King didn't mean
[ __ ]
remember for D&D this whole show doesn't
mean [ __ ] they have a Star Wars trilogy
to get to then drogon just rides off
never to be
again with Danny at a meeting of the
leaders of the Seven Kingdoms things are
going about as well as my family's
Thanksgiving dinner say another word
about killing my brother and I'll cut
your throat
Tyrion tells the group that John's fate
should be decided by the future king or
queen and then they're like hey let's
just decide here without consulting any
of our people how about the guy who
can't walk or hold a regular
conversation he'll be a good leader mad
props for those if you saw the guy who
sucked on his mom's titties in season
one and you gotta love the writers who
gave Tyrion this line there's nothing in
the world more powerful than a good
story you're damn right Tyrion I'm still
waiting for one Tyrion says who has a
better story than bran the broken
well--there's Anza area jon about half
dozen others but you know who's keeping
track so Tyrion the person who betrayed
the Queen is now telling them that Dani
would have wanted brand to be king of
all people whatever anything goes this
season and bran just tells them why do
you think I came all this way
like he friggin knew he was gonna be
king I put some answers as to how long
he knew that and here Sansa is like eff
this the north will be a free Kingdom
and none of the other kingdoms have a
problem with this or want to be free -
what tyrion just goes from being a
prisoner to hand of the king and he
doesn't want to be it but there's still
the question of Jon Snow
Jon will be sent to the Nights Watch to
appease the unsullied it's a compromise
that's also a piece of [ __ ] this was a
dude who is resurrected at the wall just
to be sent back there Wow talk about the
rightful heir to the throne getting this
short end of the stick the guy who can
talk and ride dragons and also is
single-handedly responsible for probably
saving the entire human race they're
like hey man f off to the wall o also
you can't bang chicks there's a
heartfelt goodbye between the remaining
Starks and no one is like hey remember
we had siblings Rickon and robb anyway
Arya decides to go West to live her
dream of being I don't even know and
Brenda's showing less emotion in this
goodbye than my dad on my wedding day
and now for our fanboy pandering section
of the episode what just comes across as
desperate Brienne writes that Jaime died
protecting his queen Brienne he left you
come on to be with his sister lover the
man is a piece of [ __ ] he could have had
the best redemptive
dr. Arkin all of TV history but no the
character arc fulfillments and the
seasons are among the worst I've ever
encountered and I've seen lost but if
that couldn't get any worse we have two
more scenes which are just outrageous
we have bran sitting as an advisor for
the hand of the king
you mean the guy who held the crossbow
and demanded he get payment for not
killing Jaime and Tyrion the guy who
could have had an amazing Redemption
where he puts aside his love for gold to
side with the friendships he's made for
eight seasons well with the way this
season has gone I guess anything goes I
will say Sam is the head maester one of
the few things they got right and I do
like Brienne and Davos on the council
and Podrick as the official wheelchair
puller yes Podrick you finally made your
way up in the world now I swear to God
they had to have shot this scene within
the last two weeks after so much hate
the show got after Jon didn't say
goodbye to ghost I loved that they did
it but this scene should have happened
episodes ago and now it just feels like
pandering still good boys deserve Pat's
so I won't entirely hate on it also this
dark master on the ship is pretty badass
with Arya looking off into the distance
her future unknown Sansa is essentially
crowned queen of the north and John
leads the wildlings north of the wall
now here is something that's easily
missed this little piece of plant here
likely one of the few plants to grow
north of the wall hinting that life
might just be a bit easier north of the
wall now that the night king is gone for
good
it's also fitting that the last shot of
the series contrasts the very first the
woods covered in snow
everything has come full circle except
for most of the character arcs stay
tuned because in the next few days I'll
be coming out with my how Game of
Thrones should have ended video and
you'll want to stick around for that
make sure to give the video a like and
subscribe and follow me on twitter at
things story whitey until next time
remember daddy loves you very much
[Music]